have you done voice work in animation  anyone which one um don't ask me about  cows for six point about cows  what is it cause yet home on the rest  yeah which one are you you know don't  ask me Calloway was I I don't know I  came down three on all I think I hear  one of them you're one of the and you  worked excellence people talk to be  still it came out before I had to go to  Hollywood because of a nomination for  the Oscars and it was it was when  Brokeback Mountain came out there was a  great a lot of people walking up and  down very very cross with placards and  our car was stopped and this man came up  very very angry banging on the door  window with a placard saying como on the  range wrong did we go I think about  [ __ ] about cows  why are you so angry he must know  confused  [Laughter]  [Music]  you